uh is of course Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy is up for reelection we are
enthusiastically supporting that
re-election I think the good people of
Louisiana uh know that he's done a good
job for them Senator welcome back great
to have you
thank you Sean you uh
first you mentioned electric vehicles
if electric vehicles are so swell
why does government have to pay people
to drive them
[Laughter]
I wish I thought of that that's a great
line well it's true if you think about
it number two you mentioned inflation
inflation was made in Washington since
President Biden was inaugurated 540 days
ago
prices are up
13.2 percent here's another way of
looking at that a dollar this Buck is
now worth in purchasing power about 87
maybe 88 cents
so uh what is President Biden doing
about it you might be thinking you know
people make mistakes what's he going to
do about what's he doing about it well
the president has decided to drink
himself sober
um first he passed a 750 billion dollar
so-called inflation reduction Act which
takes 300 billion dollars in higher
taxes out of the pockets of the American
people when the economy is slowing
prices are rising and 401ks are crashing
and he gives up 300 million dollars of
taxpayer money to the green New Deal
industrial complex which will properly
spend it in a way that causes Energy
prices to go up without reducing World
temperatures a scintilla of a degree
because China and India refuse to stop
emitting CO2
and then for his second trick
the president decided to spend one
trillion dollars to forgive student debt
now we already had a plan to repay
student debt it's called a job and it
was working just fine
you're on your own game
I'm not interrupting if you look at this
from 35 000 feet I think this is this is
obvious and and and that's why I say
that um President Biden is inflation's
best friend
inflation loves President Biden
inflation loves President Biden like the
devil loves sin
and I don't see where they've done
anything whatsoever except sing folk
songs
to try to stop it ravaging the American
people
you know why the celebration on a day
when inflation went up yet again Senator
and if we use the same methodology that
they used in the 1980s to calculate uh
inflation numbers we'd be at 16 percent
that's how bad it really is they just
have twice now adjusted the methodology
of how they calculate that so it's that
bad and then we've got this other little
problem well we're going to pay off
student debt the people willingly took
on and then we're going to advise our
brave men and women in the military uh
how to best get on food stamps uh maybe
the alternative would be to take the the
trillion dollars in student debt
forgiveness and maybe give it to the
military so that they can afford to pay
for the food themselves what do you
think
well of course you I think you're right
Sean but to not to put to find a point
on it but the president uh he's not
really
um forgiving student debt somebody's got
to pay for it he's just transferring it
from the people who owe it the college
Elite to the people who don't owe it uh
working class Americans but the way the
president handled handle has handled the
economy is social and economic policies
um how can I put this your aunt's
Facebook page has more credibility with
the American people than President Biden
does when it comes to the economy and
and I think I think voters are going to
go medieval on him
I mean I'm up for I'm up for reelection
if if you want to learn more about me go
to johnkannedy.com
johnkennedy.com I'm not I I'm not going
to mention any words this inflation was
made in Washington in large part by
President Biden's socio-economic
policies and you know I'm not I don't
mean to speak ill of the president but
if the shoe fits wear it Cinderella I
mean he he his policies cause this
I I I think this is probably your best
appearance Senator Kennedy I support
your re-election we're always glad to
have you on the program uh thank you for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else